So this is the advantage of streams.
You can overlap data transferring computation. And there's a subtler issue.
The ability to launch multiple kernels asynchronously at the same time on the GPU
can help you fill the GPU with smaller kernels.
Sometimes you have many problems with limited parallelism
or sometimes you're doing a computation, such as a reduction,
where there's sort of a narrow phase, the amount of work gets less and less.
And in the narrow phases, you just don't have enough work to fill up the GPU.
Well, maybe you have something else that you can start running on the GPU at the same time
to help fill up all of those SMs.
Now, there are some details to be aware of.
So check out streams and events in the CUDA Programming Guide
if you're interested in learning more.